>> Sandra: REMARKABLE AND
TOUCHING MOMENT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS WAR.
THANK YOU.
>> John: BRING IN LIEUTENANT
GENERAL KEITH KELLOGG, FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER TO
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE, SENATOR
AMERICAN SECURITY, TOUCH SCREEN,
GENERAL.
THE OVERVIEW OF UKRAINE AND WE
CAN SEE THE AMOUNT OF RED ON THE
SCREEN THAT REPRESENTS THE AREAS
UNDER RUSSIAN CONTROL IS
BEGINNING TO INCREASE.
POTENTIALLY HERE DOWN IN THE
SOUTH OF THE COUNTRY, WHERE
FORCES COMING UP FROM CRIMEA
HAVE TAKEN THE CITY OF KHERSON,
AND MOVING TOWARD MARIUPOL IN
THE NORTHEAST, MARIUPOL,
ACCORDING TO THE DEPUTY MAYOR,
UNDER BOMBARDMENT FOR SOME 26
HOURS.
AND APPARENTLY REPORTS OF
FIGHTING IN AND AROUND THE AREA
OF ENERHODAR, WHERE THE BIGGEST
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN ALL OF
EUROPE, AND GENERAL, AS FAR AS
WE KNOW, THE PLAN FOR RUSSIAN
FORCES WOULD BE TO SORT OF HOOK
WEST AND THEN WEST/SOUTHWEST TO
SURROUND THE CITY OF ODESA, THAT
WOULD GIVE THEM CONTROL OF THE
ENTIRE BLACK SEA COAST OF
UKRAINE.
WHAT KIND OF AN ADVANTAGE WOULD
THAT GIVE THEM AS THEY THEN TRY
TO MOVE ON THROUGH THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY HERE?
>> JOHN, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
ODESA IS IMPORTANT, THE THIRD
LARGEST CITY AND IF THEY TAKE
THAT, THEY HAVE SEA ACCESS.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
SEEING IS ACTUALLY NOT THE
BEGINNING OF THE END, BUT THE
END OF THE BEGINNING.
WE ARE LOOKING AT NEW STAGES,
AND THE STAGES THAT WE ARE GOING
TO WATCH AND WE SHOULD WATCH
CAREFULLY IS PUTIN GOING INTO
KYIV AND KHARKIV AND TAKING
THOSE CITIES DOWN BY
BOMBARDMENT.
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS IN EUROPE I
TOOK A SPECIAL TEAM INTO
SAREJEVO, AND HEAVY ARTILLERY
DEMOLISHED THE CITY AND CAME
BACK TO EUROPEAN COMMAND AND
SAID WE ARE GOING TO GO IN
THERE, AND EVERYBODY SAID IT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, WELL WE
WENT IN.
AND WHEN YOU SEE THE IMAGES OF
HEAVY BOMBARDMENT, THE PEOPLE OF
THE WORLD ARE GOING TO SAY THIS
MAY HAVE GONE TOO FAR AND I
THINK THE EARLIER COMMENT ABOUT
NO FLY ZONE ON THE WESTERN PART
OF UKRAINE MAY START TO TAKE
EFFECT, AND THAT MAY -- I
UNDERSTAND WHAT BRET SAID
EARLIER ABOUT THIS RAISES THE
GAME, AND RAISING THE ODDS.
BUT LOOK, SOONER OR LATER THE
PEOPLE OF THE WORLD ARE GOING TO
SAY LOOK, THIS HAS GONE WAY TOO
FAR.
REMEMBER WHEN THE BOSNIAN CIVIL
WAR ENDED, WE TOOK THE SENIOR
GENERAL OF THE BOSNIAN SERBS,
THE PRESIDENT, AND BROUGHT HIM
UP ON WAR CRIME CHARGES AND WE
ARE REACHING A PART THE
BOMBARDMENT OF A CITY LIKE KYIV
IS A WAR CRIME.
WE ARE AT THE START OF A
BRAND-NEW PHASE AND REALLY
INTERESTING TO WATCH HOW THE
WORLD REACTS TO THIS, WHEN YOU
SEE THESE VIDEO IMAGES OF A
CITY, A MODERN CITY BEING
DESTROYED BY A PREDATOR NATION
OF RUSSIA, AND HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO REACT.
I'M NOT TOO SURE THE INJURY IS
OUT ON THAT.
AND IF I WAS PRESIDENT BIDEN, I
WOULD HAVE TAKEN MY ADVISORS AND
PUT THEM IN A ROOM, COME UP WITH
EVERY OPTION YOU HAVE TO THE
WORST TO THE BEST AND BASICALLY
LIKE THEY DO IN POKER, THIS MAY
BE ALL IN.
>> John: THE IDEA OF A NO FLY
ZONE IS AN IDEA PUSHED BY
UKRAINIAN PARLIAMENT MEMBERS,
BUT THEY WANT A NO FLY ZONE OVER
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW
AMBASSADOR VOLKER AND TALKED
WITH BRET BAIER ABOUT THIS, THE
CONVOY THAT IS, A SMALL PART OF
IT, AND THIS GOES FOR 40 MILES
UP TO THE BELARUS BORDER.
AND AMBASSADOR VOLKER SAID WE
HAVE A-10, IS THAT A PROVOCATION
THAT LEADS TO OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN?
>> YEAH, I'M LOOKING AT -- I BET
THERE ARE SOME U.S. AIR FORCE
PILOTS SALIVATING AND WANTING TO
CHANGE THEIR CITIZENSHIP TO
UKRAINIAN RIGHT ABOUT NOW TO GET
IN WITH THE A-10 WART HOGS.
WE DID THAT IN WORLD WAR II, WE
SENT AMERICAN PILOTS TO FLY FOR
THE U.A.F., AND IN CHINA, THE
FLYING TIGERS, AMERICAN
VOLUNTEERS.
YOU MAY SEE SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THAT'S AN IMPRESSIVE TARGET TO
TRY TO TAKE OUT.
SOONER OR LATER, WE HAVE TO MAKE
HARD CHOICES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO BECOME A
WARTIME PRESIDENT, WHETHER HE
LIKES IT OR NOT, WE ARE KIND OF
THERE.
>> John: ALL RIGH